so I might leave this trig one till last
because we haven't done tree for a
little while which is kind of why I
wanted to review it so we'll come back
to this guy let's have a look at the
quadratics okay so number two you can
see minus seven sorry negative seven I
should say negative seven negative
eighteen you can think of the pair of
numbers can't you and you're going to
get positive to negative nine so it's
been broken apart successfully I will
point out if it's a case like this where
it's a monic quadratic and you identify
that pair of numbers you don't have to
write this intervening line you can go
straight to positive to negative nine
okay the reason why we write that in
between line the reason why we break it
apart is it makes it easier when it's
non monic like say this guy we're gonna
deal with this in a second and writing
this extra line is really helpful when
you do this but when it's monic you have
your pasta to you - line just ban
there you go you just chuck them into
the factorization and you're done
because you want them both to be equal
to zero you actually reverse the sign so
that's a nine isn't it it's a nine yes
okay thank you so nine negative T comes
up yeah fantastic now this last one at
the bottom quickly you realize you
cannot factorize which is no problem we
now know a pair of strategies that works
when you can't factorize what's the pair
of strategies what's this one this is
completing the square or alternatively
you could have done the formula okay so
I'm actually just curious who use the
formula heads up heads up straight okay
I'm interested in the heads down what I
would encourage you to do is maybe the
formulas newer so maybe you use it less
instinctively what that probably means
is you need to practice it a bit because
sometimes usually the form is just so
much faster then completing the square
other times you still need to learn how
to complete the square so those people
who prefer the formula still need to
remember how to do this let's have a
look does it look like it's been
completed successfully what's this line
about what's this for on to business
yeah you have and then you square so
having it gives you two square you it
gives you four which is white one plus
four equals five four here to here we're
kind of sort of done two things
one hit but I'm okay with it because
it's right uh you get the plus or minus
square root where did this plus two come
from yeah you you would have been left
with X minus two on the left hand side
but you know you just want X so the
person whose work this out is just added
to both sides
looks good just don't minor note I
because you had the plus minus there
it's customary to write the other number
first like so and this actually will
become useful to us a bit later on so
I'm going to encourage you to write the
other number positive or negative write
that one first and then do the plus
minus afterwards okay as promised we're
going to come back to question 1 so it's
been a little while since you've touched
these kinds of questions so let me help
you out a little bit I've started by
drawing this thing they were drawing the
quadrants okay I see that sine X is
equal to and then there's this number
what's the sign of the number like plus
minus it's a it's a negative right so
when you come over to your quadrants
which quadrants am i interested in ok
quarters 3 & 4 are the ones I want
because in those quadrants sine is
negative right another way I can say is
that sine is positive here so those are
the ones I don't want okay either way
you end up in Quadrant three in Quadrant
four we'll work out what to do with
those quadrants in a second I have to
work out the base angle now the base
angle you can use you can find rather
using sine inverse but there's something
missing here what you would do to get
the base angles you wouldn't do sine
inverse of minus you just drop off the
negative okay that will give you the
base angle you could also remember that
this city exact angle so you'll get 60
60 is not the solution 60 is not the
solution if you put sine 60 in here you
don't get minus root three on two
so what do I do with this base angle yep
sir very good I'm gonna use it to find
the virgins in quadrants three and four
so four quadrant three what do i do at
60 hold on you ted you ted
we got this one right yes that's right
okay about about a third a half of you
there's a lot of you who do not have
your hands up so I want to help you with
this so you know how to do this so your
bit Bob I'm gonna take the sixty degrees
and I'm gonna say in Quadrant three you
get 180 plus 60 whereas in Quadrant four
it's 360 takeaway sixty so my two
answers are 240 and 300 those are the
two solutions I'm expecting is that make
sense and by the way this answer here
negative 60 is not wrong it's just not
in the domain I'm interested in right
which is Norton 360 which admittedly I
forgot to write first time and add it
afterwards okay negative 60 is this
negative 60 right there so it's part of
the right answer it's just not the whole
thing